j'accueille michel galabru
michel galabru bonsoir moi je pourrais
vous connaissez base de sa part a dit et
là pas de près mais enfin je l'admirais
beaucoup de loin et de loin et la
famille alors en fait j'ai mis pour vous
annoncer la musique du gendarme de saint
tropez mais en fait j'aurais mieux fait
de mettre le générique de bouillon de
culture parce que vous êtes ici pour un
livre consacré à sacha guitry qui
s'appelle galabru raconte vitry vous
savez on fait michel galabru comme en
baisse il va vous montrer baffie
ils prennent pas les balances ton
bouquin
je sais j'ai toujours peur maintenant tu
donc vous raconter votre passion pour
guitry mais aussi sa vie lui c'est à
dire au théâtre au cinéma livre assez
complet alors avant de parler du livre
on va parler de vous parce que
finalement toute votre vie vous a amené
vers verser cherry tree d'une certaine
façon dont on va commencer avec votre
papa qui était directeur du port de safi
au maroc enfance heureuse oui oui le
premier en france oui puis après ça
s'est gâté sert qu'au maroc vous aviez
ce noir qui s'occupait de vous quitter
très gentil oui malajube le revoir il a
été très émouvant oui c'est bien que
quand on a quitté le maroc qui nous a
mis à mon frère et moi l'âme appel nous
apporter dans la cabine et et on a
pleuré je me cramponner à lui je me suis
encore l'odeur de sa peau ce qui m'est
resté là c'était formidable alors
effectivement votre père était assez
assez dur avec vous d'une certaine façon
et finalement c'est pour ça que cette
espèce d'inquiétude toujours chez vous 2
centimes en deux depuis le baby lité
wiki jacquet au québec parce que mon
père était très sévère c'était c'était
une autre époque maintenant
les parents étaient très sévères et des
braves gens mais très sévère et mon père
était navré par ce que
je ne faisais rien me renvoyer de tous
les collèges voilà mais il y avait une
peur une peur de la classe bourgeoise de
redescendre dans la classe ouvrière
plutôt que de que de monter dans la
classe reine chasse aux délits classe
était très tranchées et et alors que
l'on vous dira si vous tu passes pas
tomba qui lui pas capable de faire les
études tu travailleras de tes mains
femme en fait oui maintenant ça s'est
heureusement tout ça ça c'est
interpénétrés et on ne fait plus ou
moins trois tours de maintenance est
autant et c'est que le mec qui
travaillent dehors main il ya plein de
bleus ont bien maintenant les 2500
balmont il chausse de
bain pour bichette pas de bédénik bague
mon frère
il est
donc maintenant très bien ce qui
rapporte le plus mais alors votre père
évidemment voulait pas que vous soyez
comédien quand il vous a vu d'ailleurs
dans l'illusion comique je vais matamore
et c'est pratiquement évanouie qua non
il m'a vu parce que j'avais pris mon
costume de pour l'essayer chez moi et
quand il m'a vu le pauvre ça ici oui
c'est presque évanouie cette crise alors
là où ça devient moins drôle c'est quand
vous partez au havre parce que votre
père effectivement est nommé au havre
pour les agrandir le port du havre pour
que le paquebot normandie puisse rentrer
dans le port du havre et là c'est la
première déception de votre vie vous
êtes viré cette fois de l'école
c'est à dire que je partais d'un d'un
peuple d'un pays où d'une enfance
j'étais complètement libre c'était la
vie dans le bled on ne faisait rien même
les vagues dans une institutrice pour me
reprendre les cinq parties du monde que
j'ai jamais pu savoir et brusquement je
suis rentrée au lycée dans le brouillard
de du havre avec ces bateaux qui on
entendait les sifflements les hurlements
de d ça m'a foutu un cafard terrible et
je ne me suis jamais fait et je me
souviens est rentré donc à l'école et
launay institutrice famille dans les
chiottes c'est dans ces petits casiers
je sais pas ce que ça voulait dire je
suis resté là près d'une demi heure on
est venu me chercher vous comprenez pas
je venais d'un autre pays d'un autre
monde de liberté qu'est ce qui vous
rassurent en fait c'est vous avez été
viré cette fois de l'école mais qui te
fait 12 donc d'une certaine façon là
vous commencez effectivement à un
ensemble est ma passion c'est les
parents tout ça j'étais un cancre l'on
disait peut-être peut-être l'agriculture
sera pour lui et brusquement mettant un
livre c'était les mémoires sacha guitry
j'encourage tout le monde à lire parce
que c'est très drôle et il disait que il
avait fait 12 6e ouais je me suis apte à
accrocher à ça et ça m'a beaucoup aidé
et m'a même pas aidé à passer mon bac
j'ai eu au bout de sa foi mais je les ai
eus quand même parce que je me suis
intéressé à tout ce dont il parle est un
écrivain un peintre musicien j'étais
passionné pour se surpasser à ce point
que je suis rentré j'ai dû souffler un
petit peu de culture quoi je suis
pudique culture alors vous rêvez au
départ d'être professionnel de football
oui j'ai déjà le début du cabotinage
parce que ces types qui joue au ballon
et qui se faisait applaudir m'avait
séduit tout de suite blessé ça et alors
vous avez à montpellier et votre tante
vous fait écouter des disques de sacha
guitry yvonne printemps oui là c'est la
vocation à c'était yvonne printemps le
sache et la piété la sacha guitry c'est
un disque qui essaient de labour masqué
vient s'il est vrai que tu m'as tu en
viens dans les bras que je te tends bras
et l'autre change pas lui savait pas
chanter et ils volent le printemps
chante avec une voix extraordinairement
ravissante c'est dommage que l'on a pu
oublier parce que c'est une voie
ravissant et ça se décide de votre
passion votre vocation films dont
progrès pour le torino rossi au début
ouais j'imitais tino rossi le son de
ckoi tino marinella c'est comme marie
della
valle
il a une pêche le gala régional
[Musique]
vous lui ressemblez à assécher guitry et
vous vous achetez des bagues comme lui
au monoprix à béziers d'essayer de
ressembler à sa liste mais je m'étais
les bacs jeu tiré sur mes chemises comme
ça pour l'un et toute la journée comme
ça même le votre pseudo c'était michel
livry donc c'est une limitation sera pas
pour accrocher un peu de 2,7 consonance
quoi guitry livry ça faisait deux sexes
et c'est l'identification quoi
l'admiration telle qu'on s'identifie
puis après on s'aperçoit qu'il faut même
si votre verre est tout petit il vaut
boire dans votre verre et puis abandonné
tous ses rêves où vous décidez de monter
à paris donc et pour ça quand vous
montez pour voir l'argent de faire le
voyage votre frère vend sa collection de
timbres enfin tout le monde s'est cotisé
pour mieux j'ai perdu un petit fono que
j'avais à l'époque c'était les trucs
avec la manivelle tous mes disques donc
il y avait du sacha guitry y avait des
grandes de diction de grands sociétaires
d'accueil française parce que ça me
passionnait j'ai vendu tout ça j'ai pris
le train
je me souviens et en partant il mes
parents n'ont rien voulu me dire ma mère
faisait des frites et je voyais ses
larmes fut tombée dans le freight je
pense à mon père qui les a bouffés après
et après j'ai croisé mon père qui
revenait du bureau qui a simplement levé
sa cave le désespoir et j'ai abouti à
paris comme ça votre père vous est
effondré vos parents à vii est terrible
et d'un maire qui était tellement gentil
elle visait à mon père ne lui donne pas
d'argent comme ça il sera obligé de
revenir et il n'a pas donné mais j'ai
trouvé les boulots de cas et voulait que
vous rentriez au contentieux dans une
boîte qui s'appellerait cned recette
brute s'est frayé et à 23 ans vous
débarquez à paris 1 ou 2 paris mais
sélectionnable je me suis trouvé en haut
des champs elysées on a ce sentiment de
décrit par balzac ou de paris quoi tout
le monde avait un petit peu simple et
vous retrouvez contrôleurs au tnp oui
parce que oui je chante de bonneville à
l'eau c'est déjà un peu moins drôle
c'était une chambre de bonne 8 rue lalau
1 il y avait là une la file la concierge
qui s'appelait et me dubois essaimé
premier verre à mon aimé aimer dubois
qui devant l'amour ne plus jamais de
bois je dévisse et quelques verres que
ce sont deux mois car aimer mais c'est
tout c'est du bois
francs à l'époque jean babilée danger
et vous aller avec eux de dunedin s oui
c'est un grand sociétaires étaient déjà
bien également et qui était très très
très dur très sévère et laura l'époque
un jour devant l'église de la madeleine
vous rencontrez un pote à vous qui
s'appelle pignol champignol et qui vous
disent qu'un marne selon sa famille sont
tous drôle ton père est drôle toi tu es
drôle et finalement tu te tue pourquoi
est-ce que tu t'occupes de choses
sérieuses c'est une remarque qui m'a
fait qui m'a aidé beaucoup et c'est
comme ça que j'ai commencé à regarder
mon père ses intonations et me suis
aperçu que qu'il y avait beau il fallait
chercher dans ses racines sa petite
personnalité c'est effectivement je les
imiter c'est en limitant que j'ai eu mon
premier effet comique ça je me dis voilà
la bonne voie c'est très curieux et
après trois ans de conservatoire
finalement vous qui avez toujours tout
raté la non vous avez le premier prix
tout mini classique comédie moderne oui
alors là c'est mon père l'était s'est
aperçu que c'était un peu trompé le
pauvre parce que c'était un bourgeois
jeu ça les oeufs au cinéma ou sur les
boulevards il verrait pas mais que je
rentre avec rudy françaises ca de la
comédie française chez les bourgeois
c'est surtout à cette époque la presse
du comique française un grand prestige c
était lent et c'est on est venue
m'interviewer c'est le monde qui est
venu matière visiter le journal que
disait mon père comme
gens sérieux et ça ça m'a foutu sur le
plus voilà vous rentrez la colonie
française etc robbery assez
croustillante renvoyé à clarens la
grande époque nous étions terrorisés
vous répétiez les rôles toute la nuit
terrorisante parce qu' il fallait
apprendre quelques fois pour remplacer
quelqu'un pied levé un rôle de 800
lignes il me les comptes et moi parce
que en quatre jours cinq jours c'était
effrayant même des trouilles n'a pas été
nous couper la parole ça fait deux
soeurs qui vient rien
c'est parce qu'ils n'avaient plus
d'intérêt pour vous que sur moi parce
que je suis très fan de galawa donc
j'étais ma femme vanessa paradis
chacun ses idoles merde non c'est pas ça
ce qu'il faut dire c'est que vous savez
que laurent maintenant est devenu un
auteur dramatique réputé et donc
effectivement j'imagine qu'un jour il va
vous faire jouer dans une pièce fait
attention mais je vais y aller
que j'invite oui
je devais être au premier rang entre
150 et en fait le premier film qui
s'appelle ma femme ma vache et moi si
vous commenciez régime iranien c'est le
seul annoncé que celle dont je parle
jvous fait comme j'ai pu il a fallu
attendre quand même 20 ans pour vous
fassiez le viager et puis le juge et
l'assassin oui chef-d'oeuvre way
200 films combien de navets sûr de son
film si on est moins aisée
180 ch un guichet alors tous ces navets
voulait fusiller parce que vous aviez
des impôts à payer des entendu des
pensions alimentaires vous aviez deux
ménages vous savez je vais très prudent
parce que votre éviction est écoutée
chez moi et donc nous allons partiez si
vous voulez un inconnu si vous voulez
bien de cette émission est regardée dans
deux foyers oui
on sait pas disney
alors très en forme c'est vrai que des
fois vous êtes un peu il ya des
chaussettes cyclothymique vous un oui
mais il ya des choses et abattu mais
josette vous êtes en forme avec sa
dépense jugée si bien comme chèque barré
journée ouais
et pour des raisons précises ou sans
nombre pour supporter d'ailleurs la
nature humaine est très difficile à
comprendre je ne me comprends pas encore
moi-même et je crois qu'il n'y a rien à
comprendre
c'est un c'est vrai le monde est dans la
merde
comme ne se comprend pas soi même on ne
faut pas pas les autres on n'en finit
plus on est mal informé en fait
[Applaudissements]
non c'était parce que vous croyez pas en
dieu vous avez pas la foi vous n'êtes
pas croire parce que je trouve que dire
le bon dieu c'est grâce à m'interpeller
comment du bon dieu et que tous les
saloperies qui est d'une boule lui il ya
une boule de terre une boule si un dieu
comme et tout puissant il l'a foutu dans
l'atmosphère et la parsemer de microbes
et après faut remercier si ça ne me
vient pas l'idée je ne prétends je suis
bluffé humble je ne comprends pas je dis
je ne comprends pas je ferme ma gueule
enfin je ne peux pas remercier ça ne
vient pas comme ça sacha guitry disait
lui en parlant du moindre signe ça c'est
génial savoir s'il serait le bienvenu
parce que depuis le temps que ce prix il
ferait quand même un jour même il serait
gentil quand même et vous ça vous avez
la foi vanessa oui je crois en dieu je
crois que tout le bordel qu'il ya dans
le monde il n'a pas été créé par dieu
mais par les hommes
je voudrais bien mais comme dieu a créé
les hommes
c'est infernal comme truc on lui a rien
demandé
moi non plus et ensuite les suites r
j'avais déjà à pêcher sur la gueule non
bon mais si vous êtes peut-être raison
vous savez je souhaite qu'ils rsca ton à
la fois c'est merveilleux parce qu'on se
dit bah je vais aller au ciel mais
personne n'est jamais revenu il ya des
milliards de cadavre et personne ne
revient
ça devient suspect
on va pas le culte dont faisait la brute
à quoi les jeunes
bravo laurent
ma promo ah oui tu fais que pour tâcher
de ma gueule tu es fou un des gymnases
aille vite venu vénale
bien alors
guitry vous à quelque part tout à porter
parce que vous dites d'ailleurs quand il
parlait d'un peintre j'essayais d'en
savoir plus sur lui quand il décrivait
le fond ça les jeunes gens lisaient les
bouquins en fait vous auriez voulu être
sacha guitry voilà jamais de sacha
guitry faisons galabru voilà un peu
dramatique la baguette souris peut pas
rien faire alors votre livre commence à
53 donc c'est un jeune homme qui arpente
une rue du côté du champ de mars il a
une lettre d'introduction pour
rencontrer sacha guitry hélios pas
monter oui parce que oui mais abc il m'a
dit le montrent pas parce qu'il va il
est en haut de l'escalier votre regard
des ventes et tu t'en sortir à jamais
c'était très intimidé je suis donc resté
sur un banc en face sa maison c'est
terrible parce que je le voyais tous les
jours parce que j'habite est pas loin je
voyais même ceux se coiffer j'ai vu j'ai
assisté presque à sa mort c'était
terrible parce que les journalistes
étaient là tous attendant des temps la
mort comme sa mort du roi et on a vu
vers 2 3 heures du matin fermez les
volets on a compris qu'il était mort
c'était une terrible pour moi moi j'ai
eu l'impression que que ma vie était
finie est tellement j'aimais cet homme
mais j'admirais oui j'ai beaucoup
intéressé ces histoires d'amour parce
qu'elle avait beaucoup les oui oui dans
la vie paraît que tu es très timide
femme est très timide lui très timide
alors comme il savait pas faire la cour
de l'offre et des cadeaux à 9 heures
elle recevait une
fourrure à 10 heures une belle robe à
11h en bisous à toi demande peut pas
faire ça bien obligé de parler à un
moment donné
et pendant la guerre vitry a été quand
même puis vous savez il faut se méfier
parce que la rumeur publique tout ça
quand on crie haro la foule est terrible
et souvent est mal informé et il a
continué à jouer mais on a joué du jean
paul sartre ont amené en apparente sur
les pas pris à eux il a continué à jouer
mais je crois qu'il a fait beaucoup de
bien sauvé beaucoup de juifs qui
beaucoup de gens disent adressé à lui
qui après quand il a été arrêté ont eu
peur de le remercier et de témoigner et
j'ai assisté à sa première conférence
quand il est libéré à la salle pleyel et
il a il a eu là le public tout de suite
il dit je suis terminée par un non lieu
dont il n'y avait pas lieu ça et c'est
un peu vrai
voilà donc
bien la rue raconte du
scénario
[Musique]
c'est passionnant
alors dites moi vous avez perdu votre
virginité à l'âge de 18 ans avec mona
oui
moi je n'avais aucun d'eux ou super
parce que j'ai pas beaucoup de succès
auprès des femmes et j'allais donc dans
la région bordelaise vous comprenez ce
que je veux dire et
donc c'est mona qui a eu l'honneur de
meute et booster un chien
chien crée de la monnaie oui c'est
possible et là c
est alors en plus c'est pas vrai non
plus pas vrai parce que vous avez
prévenu elle vous avez dit tu vas être
déçu oui c'est vrai mais vous l'avez
choisie parce qu'elle avait une montre
et je le dis comme ça au moins je suis
sûr de rentrer facilement perdre donner
des leçons de matisse à soyaux et tout
ça c'est pénible à dire aimer ce nageuse
la plus curieux c'est que quand je suis
allé m'ont payé jouez ya pas tellement
longtemps on va présenter le fils de
monard c'est dingue ce g20 grenelle
[Applaudissements]
alors il était tellement excusez moi
monsieur que j'étais tellement plus haut
que quand elle vous dit va faire ta
petite toilette vous laver les pieds
parce que votre mère et ma mère doivent
des duels avec toujours les pires heures
du conte
devant la femme on est tourné peu de
choses ça vous impressionne pas besoin
d'être en face d'une très jolie femme
comme un oui vous savez j'ai été
impressionné avant de venir savez trés
mais on m'a dit il ya vanessa et comme
je ne la connais pas que je dois voir à
la télé tout ça je me suis dit ouh là là
bas on modifie elle est très gentille on
va dire mais
les ballons hauts et les belles en plus
bien alors on va vous faire vous savoir
un peu mieux qui vous êtes on va vous
faire une interview psy
[Musique]
on ne bouge pas pendant le single
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous êtes mégalo oh non plus tout non
vous êtes mito non plus d'être parano
nos peu schizo à chaque fois que ça tout
le monde est un peu s'attend à un homme
enfin bon moi je suis un peu de seins
quand même ouais j'ai beaucoup de
défauts mais le fait d'être si klaus est
par définition un peu schizo cyclo un
peu oui les cyclos c'est ce qu'ils ont
une formule est maso non non pas du tout
vous aimez pas qu'on vous fasse mal oh
non non on me
trouve ça con alors là il ya des gens
qui adorent ça oui oui pareil balance
alors là
vous voulez pas changer
c'est tellement con
enfin bon est ce que vous êtes sado
shadow non plus non mais pas faire du
mal aux genevois
moi j'ai pitié d'un poulet ou pas
mais non vous êtes homo ou alors non
après tout peut arriver
vous pouvez arriver là tout peut arriver
vous étiez petit au maroc
pourquoi vous dites ça comme au body
collet et aux français aussi vous avez
d'avoir des propositions aux français ce
jeu vous dire donc je ne me suis jamais
furent papa août et si vous voulez que
je vous dise c'est un peu verdun de ce
côté là mais il y avait beaucoup il y
avait beaucoup de domofrance et de gens
qui y avait beaucoup de talent et on a
lancé dans les régions vous savez ils
ont tendance à vous féminisé et on
m'avait féminisé lors d'une tournée
parce que j'étais avec vous appelez la
galabru non rendement m'appeler parce
que c'était robert hirsch il avait
beaucoup de l'esprit et m'appeler rosa
pichon en et rosa pulsions et bien vous
savez on se sent un peu femme à ce
moment là
c'est pas aller plus loin non non non
non on est resté à rosas bon est ce que
vous êtes gros lolos gros lolos ah oui
mais bon
je suis aussi petit lolo je suis leur
lot complet voilà c'est un corsage tous
extraordinaires et je regrette de ne pas
y avoir quoi que bah quoi que oui
est ce que vous êtes trio trio à
attention et à la fin je vais pas être
faut il faut des rejets dans mon temps à
l'époque
une trio j'ai goûté ouais c'est pas
mauvais mais avec deux femmes pas bon
alors mais canon parce que vous êtes
exhibo non pas du tout djibo en acteur
est toujours existant en eau qui me gêne
c'est le principe de cette interview
elle se reprend bien et celle de labro
le gala voilà certains films on le voit
poids non c'est vrai s'il y en a un mais
vous l'avez loupé j'étais figurant dans
la bataille buffet est beatles et pas
sur les pompiers et
ont passé des clés l'ailé comme on
appelle ça le conseil de révision donc
comme j'étais figurants on nous habite
tous nus et moi j'ai eu le malheur de me
trouvais juste à la porte du médecin
donc pour raccorder au mal et c'est là
toute une journée tout nu avec la script
qui dotés tous les états
travelo de travaux n'ont jamais essayé
la gt gt d'un 4e fois que j'étais enfin
bon travelo est commun
femmes et acteur l'alu automne yahtzee
devais me rouler une pelle et la refuser
pourquoi il à dire me voyante et aurore
voulait très bien composé
est ce que vous êtes recontre rocco et
ses frères encore que ces frais d un
gros merci fred et rocco siffredi ouais
qu'est-ce qu'ils ne connaissaient pas
rocco siffredi non je ne sais pas on
peut aussi freiner ligne puisqu'il peut
excuser mais jamais un poney à la
campagne
qu'est ce que c'est rocco siffredi sait
pas se taper un poney
ah oui mais frayer un peu tout
c'est un type qui est monté comme un âne
ah non non non non non j'ai pas de
détails vous dire mais j'ai pas rocco
ses parts au coccyx poko assez pour
cause
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous êtes adamo achats d'or a
d'abord est ce que vous êtes disco au
blond qui est plus de mon âge je crois
va essayer
[Musique]
galabru raconte vitry j'ai bien marion
brown
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu